ese conteo avanza de nuevo muy
lentamente para que os hagáis una idea
desde ayer solo se ha avanzado menos del
1% en ese recuento de votos como decías
pensilvania podría ser la llave directa
a la casa blanca para el demócrata joe
biden pero la pregunta ahora es cuándo y
bien esto que comentaba es precisamente
esa apelación es esa proclamación de la
corte suprema que ha aceptado la
petición del partido republicano de
separar los votos llegados después del 3
de noviembre pero con fecha anterior al
3 de noviembre podría ralentizar este
proceso esos votos se van a apartar y se
contarán aparte pero como digo esto
podría demorar todavía más ese conteo en
estos momentos aquí en pensilvania
todavía quedan cerca de 90.000 papeletas
por abrirse y si hacemos caso a la
tendencia que hemos visto hasta ahora
esas papeletas podrían favorecer
notoriamente a los demócratas porque
hasta ahora esas papeletas por correo
así ha sido le han favorecido a los
demócratas y además provienen de los
puntos más demócratas de este estado así
que esa diferencia esa ventaja de 28.000
133 motos que lleva ahora mismo el
demócrata joe biden podría verse
ampliada am en el candidato demócrata se
ha mostrado cauto pero bastante confiado
en su llegada a la casa blanca se
conocen detalles sobre si ya se prepara
para asumir el poder
y valentín ayer desde luego no se
proclamó oficialmente ganador pero sí
que dejó claros cuáles son los temas
principales de su agenda y sí que vimos
movimiento en cuanto a esa preparación
para su llegada a la casa blanca y
hervimos un equipo de seguridad bastante
reforzado joe biden tiene un equipo de
seguridad desde marzo ya pero lo de ayer
estaba mucho más aumentado además entre
los círculos más cercanos en el equipo
de baile ya anuncian algunos nombres que
podrían estar dentro de su próxima
administración por ejemplo en el jefe
del jefe de gabinete una de las personas
candidatas podría ser el que fue jefe de
su gabinete el que fue jefe de gabinete
cuando él fue ex presidente y el que
llevó la respuesta ante el ébola durante
el mandato de barack obama otro nombre
importante que suena es el de el excel
cirujano general de obama que al parecer
ha sido quien le ha asesorado en esta
pandemia que también podría ayudarle a
hacer frente como él decía ayer a evitar
que hayan más muertes por el coronavirus
aquí en eeuu